we'd have to get off right up here at
the Medical Center and walk like another
15 minutes to get to us the
it would end up being like a two-hour
by a full-time Harry Potter now you're
no longer the wizard no longer any kind
of chemical engineer no quit the day job
I was a biochemistry undergrad really
yeah you got your degree yeah
we can talk shop probably not yeah yeah
drop biochem man never notice how like
when people are on TV and they don't
really look at the road when they drive
check out this industrial park yeah
isn't this cool
is this where we're going yes
this is where II suppose you know that's
what I love is that he's got this
commitment to this industrial park where
you can get wholesale Chinese kitchen
supply that's part of the adventure you
know you know you don't know don't know
if that's gonna be there
so next time you're here will hopefully
be more can you talk up the Vietnamese
sandwiches like they're gonna be really
life-altering not really this place has
its own unique charm and then it's maybe
one of the dirtiest looking
doors you'll ever open into a place that
you will actually eat everything what do
you mean by everything I can see your
soul how does it look
whoa I can't see a kissy concrete that's
the thing I can't see can't you pull
there concrete can you see the poles and
concrete souls did they seem fulfilled
no I'm not gonna
they don't actually it makes me it makes
me wait for them I can't breathe through
my nose that's my first reaction but I
don't know if you notice to do when
you're wearing them you can see more
people than when you're not wearing them
I'm just going to assume that those are
dead people so these are dead people
glasses right maybe they're alien I
wasn't really picking up on that in the
hotel they probably weren't ready dead
yeah probably need more sunlight
then ever there is anyone here who foot
ailments yeah what are you gonna mix
that with exactly the three drops of
ginger ale we have love stuff yeah
you're like I get I gave you but I all
want to get drunk it's very good
composites we're gonna get drunk for
charity